you know I know you know I'll talk about
Walmart I know it's more of us centric
play what works out of business the
biggest retailer in America is at a
business it's just a matter of time now
right they didn't do the right strategy
to the world we're about to live in over
the last decade Amazon did and the games
over
mitts over they have the end whoever has
the end customer wins Amazon has the
data has the customers they're building
13 warehouses in the US right now to do
same-day delivery within the same day of
your delivery and October because we're
lazy
we value time that's what we care about
when I invested in uber people like
nobody's gonna pay for that I'm like
they may not pay for a premium black car
service but people gonna buy time
because you value money your health and
time that's what uber sells time that's
what Amazon's gonna sell at same-day
delivery time that's where we live in
and so we're living from massive massive
culture shifts one that I think people
are grossly under estimating one that
people get very comfortable in oh we
thought all these things were going to
happen then they don't and then they
really go out of business
the reason Borders bookstore went out of
business in the US was because Amazon
came along in 95 got all the hype the
2000 Internet bubble came Amazon lost 91
percent of its value in the stock market
not in actually how they were doing with
customers in the stock market and
borders decided they were going to take
advantage of this opportunity and they
let Amazon do their distribution online
they didn't build their own capabilities
and Amazon paid them there's literally
border executives I know that said
they'd laughed in the boardroom when
they made the deal that Amazon was going
to do all the work for them and they
were getting paid meanwhile it was all
just collecting customer data collecting
customer data and in 36 months borders
was basically out of business the key
thing is this everybody wants to know
what the ROI is right now and just
because there isn't an ROI at this exact
second doesn't mean that it's not
valuable to do the lack and I come from
retail family business where it wasn't
about how many impressions you got or
how many awards you won and [ __ ] can
it was about if we didn't sell [ __ ]
Pinot Noir we weren't gonna eat right
so it was results-driven and the only
thing I ever talked about and thought
about and the only way I story told and
the only way that I marketed was about
lifetime value and percentage of wallets
spent something that I have heard zero
of since I've come to corporate and
agency America and that to me is the
opportunity who here actually cares
about their customer who here wants to
have a customer forever who here wants
to execute and it starts with having a
great product but it also means how to
properly story-tell in the world we
actually live in contextual